The Matrix Revolutions welcome back to
my brief matrix series leading up to
John with Chapter two starring Keanu
Reeves and Laurence Fishburne the
perfect time for me to fill in the gaps
in my Matrix trilogy reviews I already
reviewed the matrix back in the day and
I just reviewed reloaded so let's talk
about the finale of the Matrix trilogy
the one that would hopefully bring it
all home that would finally give us that
matrix film we were hoping for after the
first unfortunately that didn't quite
happen do I hate the Matrix Revolutions
no do I think it's more the worst movies
ever made no do I think it's a very
disappointing sequel yes and just so you
know there's going to be full spoilers
for The Matrix Revolutions so if you
haven't seen these films I would check
them out and then come back and watch my
review this movie opens up with neo in a
train station his mind is there but his
body is still back in the real world and
this place is known as mobile Avenue
which of course is an anagram for limbo
a place between life and death and he
has to somehow get out of this place so
Trinity and Morpheus go and visit the
Merovingian who resides over this train
station and by doing so they have to
press a button that says help with the P
crossed out oh I wonder if the mayor of
engine is supposed to be the devil I
mean he's only dressed in red and black
even says this we only want to talk oh
yes I'm sure you do you have folks who
held to do so this is one of my biggest
problems with revolutions it's a film
that has a lot of symbolism but it's not
the type of symbolism where you have to
kind of dig and discover it for yourself
it's all extremely in your face and it's
so unmissable that if you honestly don't
see it you're just not paying attention
so we get a few fun action sequences one
that was kind of a precursor to what
they perfected in movies like Inception
and Doctor Strange and in this movie
Agent Smith has almost assimilated the
entire matrix almost everyone in the
matrix now is a Smith you wouldn't
really know that unless you kind of read
into the backstory of the film it's not
very clear in the movie which is a major
problem with the screenplay there's a
lot of elements that require a lot of
research to understand because certain
things make a lot of sense and all these
years later I understand the Matrix
Revolutions just fine
I mean I saw this movie back in 2003
it's 2017 now and I've seen it many
times I don't dislike The Matrix
Revolutions because I don't get it
that's probably the most simple and
least thought out retort that you can
say to someone who doesn't share an
opinion with you on a film oh you know
you just didn't get it you know cuz cuz
you know I'm smarter than you
you know I've deeply analyzed
revolutions I've watched it probably at
least 10 times I've read a lot of quotes
from the Wachowskis I've watched all the
documentaries and featurettes I can get
my hands on my issue with The Matrix
Revolutions is not how everything
connects it's not the overarching
symbolism it's the filmmaking on display
there's a lot of terrible dialogue in
this movie that's delivered awfully by
actors there's a lot of really bad
performances there is an overabundance
of characters that well and reloaded
took a backseat to the incredible action
sequences that were in that film here
get a lot of focus because there's also
an extreme lack of action in the Matrix
Revolutions there's a big gigantic
robots vs. robots scene where people are
piloting these things with guns it looks
sort of like makeshift Gundams except
they have no armor in front of them and
they're just completely open to attack
which is a terrible weapon the Sentinels
are invading Zion and Commander Locke
who by the way is an awful character
tries to stop this attack while neo and
Trinity are stuck on a ship somewhere
trying to get to the machine world
because neo is having visions of the
Machine world and feels that he must go
there that that's where he can end the
war
now I thought in Matrix Reloaded people
wore sunglasses too much it made it
really hard to connect with our
characters and it was just not
believable they would fly off in a
second but everyone just keeps her
sunglasses on even better than Indiana
Jones can keep that hat on but in this
movie neo loses his physical eyes so he
wears a blindfold for the entire last
half of the movie and it makes it really
hard to connect with him as a character
to me this was a plot device to make him
develop his real-world powers where he
could start seeing things in the gold
code of the matrix he suddenly was able
to control sentinels in the real world
destroying them he had a weird
connection with the source but as I said
there is an overabundance of characters
in this movie captain Mifune captain
Locke the council
all of these characters just feel like
filler it all just feels like stuff that
could be forgotten there's the one kid
who is obsessed with neo who gets this
incredibly cheesy moment yeah
movie just doesn't balance these
characters very well I do like Niobe
Giada Pinkett Smith I think she's really
good in this movie I like Z and her
partner running around in the catacombs
blasting the machines
I still like Linc I thought he was a
better addition over tank and reloaded I
liked the character of Linc I think he's
a lot of fun but from the 58 minute mark
of this movie all the way to the 85
minute mark neo is nowhere to be found
he completely vanishes from this story
because he's just on a ship somewhere
there's barely a connection with our
hero in this movie and from a filmmaking
standpoint it makes watching the film
kind of boring yeah there's a big action
sequence with the Sentinels and the
humans in Zion it's a lot of really cool
special effects but it kind of just
comes off as special effects it's a big
bloated orgy of explosions in your face
that doesn't have the same impact
fulness that the first film or even the
second one had also Agent Smith in this
movie kind of becomes a mad scientist
when he's eventually able to assimilate
the Oracle he actually does this
ah
so when trying to get to the machine
world Trinity dies and now neo has
nothing and he understands that he has
to go find the source and the source
actually is a bunch of robots that
create a giant head with a voice I'm
sorry I just I can't help but see how
dumb that is it's just the robots form a
head that speaks here's an idea
neo has already been shown to have a
connection with these machines he's
having visions of the machine city he's
able to destroy these sentinels with his
own thoughts forget about the floating
robot head that can talk he should be
able to learn all this on his own this
robot head with a deep voice is clearly
just there for us as audience members
they could have found a much more
interesting way for him to get jacked
into the matrix but this is whether
wachowski z' really falls short in
screenwriting they don't always respect
their audience they spell things out for
us a lot I like to be reminded the city
survives because of these machine these
machines are keeping us alive while
other machines are coming to kill us so
we need machines and they need us
because sometimes it does seem like they
think we're too dumb to figure it out on
our own nevertheless we're finally gonna
get the big scene where neo and Smith
fight I've always loved the one nodding
Smith in the background he's like hey
hey you're gonna get it neo there's
gratefully a little bit less of the
Agent Smith balloon people that were so
ever-present in Matrix Reloaded in this
scene there's still an overuse of CGI
that doesn't really hold up anymore but
as this scene progresses the movie
becomes more confusing unless you're
paying attention basically neo realizes
that he can't defeat Smith and fix
everything he has to allow Smith to
assimilate him so when Smith does since
neo was connected to the source the
source can now use that connection to
destroy all of the Smiths
the reason neo knew what he had to do is
because the Oracle inside Smith said
this
as a beginning as an end which is what
she said to him earlier in the film
which jogs his memory it's also the
first time that Smith has ever called
him neo and not mr. Anderson
so neo makes the ultimate sacrifice
essentially becoming Jesus
they even cart him away as he has his
arms spread out like he's on the
crucifix there's even a big beam of
light that emits from his chest like a
cross this symbolism is so heavy-handed
that it just gets too much and I wish
that it was a little bit more light
where you could just sort of read into
it but it's literally just like hey all
of this is this
so as the matrix is rebooted and they
try again and people are now given the
option to free themselves if they wish
this little girl sati apparently made a
sunset for neo so I guess this little
program sati has a considerable amount
of power what does this have to do with
anything I just want to see certain
things happen in this film with the
characters I've grown to appreciate but
there's an overabundance of all these
extra characters I haven't even talked
about serif or half the commanders of
various ships it's just this big
gigantic bloated film that was very
disappointing and I'm not talking about
the story connections I'm fine with how
they chose to resolve all of this it all
makes sense to me from a filmmaking
perspective The Matrix Revolutions is a
very convoluted experience with some
very poor performances some very jilted
dialogue and extreme lack of action
considering Reloaded overabundance of it
and an overarching failure to understand
what made audiences connect with the
first film so much I'm going to give the
Matrix Revolutions a C again not a
terrible movie as I said I have watched
this probably at least 10 times I've
analysed it very deeply well guys in
both of my previous matrix reviews I did
in fact show you a clip from one of my
earliest short films that was inspired
by The Matrix and this one was very
directly inspired by Matrix Revolutions
I want to say this was o for when I
decided to alone with no one but a
camera a tripod in my old house make a
film making fun of the matrix and I did
I want to say I was about 15 or 16 years
old here so enjoy that also since I've
covered the
tricks films even though this next film
has nothing to do with John wick chapter
2 just for continuity sake and my own
personal OCD I'd like to talk about the
Animatrix so that's going to be very
soon look forward to that guys as always
if you like this in a minute you can
click right here and get stuck my next
you
good evening mr. Anderson it is lovely
to see you Smith it ends tonight Smith
I'm sure it does mr. Anderson but I
don't understand one thing perhaps you
could lend me some of your knowledge
tonight it ends I see mr. Anderson then
we fight to the death why why is the
universal question mr. Anderson why is
the question asked by so many people and
so many people do not understand why
this universal paradox of why is trapped
us in this world of the matrix the
answer to your question mr. Anderson is
an answer in itself the answer of the
question is a choice and the choice is a
choice that you must make by the end of
tonight you will know the answer
you